-There are times where
I'm so happy
to be gone from "SNL"
because I do not miss the grind.
-Wh-a-at?
-And I do not miss the hours
but then there are times where
I'm so jealous
of the current situation,
because it was announced,
in December, that Eddie Murphy
is gonna come and host.
-Oh, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean -- I mean...
-Man, my heart exploded...
-Yeah.
-...when I heard that.
Like, there's nobody more iconic
and beloved by my entire family.
-Yeah. From like the 2-year-ol
all the way up, right?
-Like way up.
Like, great-great-great-grandma.
Like, checking in in their las
days, like, "Ooh, he's funny."
[ Laughter ]
-Does that put a burden on you
to kind of think, "Oh, my God.
I gotta come up with ideas
for that one"?
-Yeah,
I've been writing already.
You know what I mean?
I don't think
they're great ideas, like,
in comparison to what he can do.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to just be like,
"Just do whatever you want."
You know what I'm saying?
-Right, right, right.
-But, yeah, it's a burden.
And it's also --
I mean, I feel like
he feels the stress, too.
You know, it's his --
You know, he's the prodigal son.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You know what I mean?
-It's been a long time away,
but I can't imagine
it won't be anything
but fantastic.
One of his many famous
impressions was Stevie Wonder.
You got to see Stevie Wonder
perform -- this year?
-It was last Global Citizen.
-Okay, Global Citizen.
It's a great event.
-It was Green Day
and Stevie Wonder headlining
-Yeah.
-And I didn't have tickets
but this is New York.
So I felt like
this'll get me kind of close
-Yeah.
-You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
-So, that's sounds --
That really speaks
to how beloved you are,
because that was
a high-security event,
like, how many times did
your face have to be a ticket?
-It was like seven checkpoints
-Yeah.
It was just, like, "Come on.
Like, really?"
[ Laughter ]
"It's just us."
It was more of a tough sel
for my wife,
to, like, drag her through that.
-Right.
-She's like,
"Are you sure it's gonna work?
And I was like,
"I don't really know."
[ Laughter ]
"And I don't care."
Yeah, you know, they're all just
people at all those checkpoints.
You know what I'm saying?
So once you engage them
on a human level, it's like,
"What's it really gonna take?"
You know, "Radio
somebody ahead or whatever."
Anyway...
We get in there.
It all works out,
and Green Day destroys it,
and then Stevie Wonder
gets up there, and he's just -
You know, he's massive.
His sound is so mas--
You forget, like,
what concerts are like
if you don't go a lot,
and it's way different
from the album.
So, like, he's up there
with like 2 trillion peopl
onstage with him.
-Yeah.
-It seemed, like --
And he's just crushing it.
And then he was gonna do a due
with Pharrell, but I guess
Pharrell was running late.
-Okay.
-Or something like that,
and I'm like,
"How do you run late
on Stevie Wonder?"
[ Laughter ]
So, like I don't know if the
didn't tell Stevie beforehand,
but it was, like, kind of
the time to do the song,
so he's, like --
Stevie Wonder's up there
ad-libbing and killing tim
for Pharrell, search--
And, like, shouting
his name out -- "Pharrell!
[ Laughter ]
"Pharrell, where you at?!
Get out here!"
[ Laughter ]
"We got a song to do."
And then he'd, like,
tell a little story
or something like that.
"But back to Pharrell.
Where is he?"
[ Laughter ]
It's, like "Oh, man.
The guy's --"
-He was also --
he was talking his way
through the seven checkpoints.
-Yes. Yes.
It was a great night,
but, you know,
Pharrell eventually showed up,
but it was really funny.
-You co-hosted "Bring the Funny"
this year.
-That was a fun one.
Did you guys
see "Bring the Funny"?
-It's a comedy --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Comedy competition show on NBC
-NBC, baby.
-Did you enjoy --
Was it hard to sort of
criticize other people's comedy,
especially, young,
up-and-coming people?
-I mean, it wasn't hard.
I just didn't want to be, like
harsh or, like, super-negative
You know what I mean?
'Cause that's how we all felt.
We didn't know if the show
was gonna work
because nobody
was being mean enough,
and we didn't know --
Like, we didn't have a Simon
Like, Jeff is a sweetheart
and Chrissy couldn't be nicer,
and even, Amanda, you know
she's a great stand-up,
so she knows what it's lik
to be on the other side
of that rejection,
and we all did.
So I just wanted to give mor
constructive type criticis
as opposed to just,
like, "That sucks."
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
Like -- It was --
It worked out.
It was really cute,
and it was heartfelt,
and I think it --
you know, it made a splash
among good-hearted people.
-Well, that's great.
-Because good-hearted people
check in, and they're like
"You know,
I really enjoy that show."
And I'm like,
"And how old are you, sir?
[ Laughter ]
-David Remnick's
coming out next.
You're doing The New Yorke
Festival this weekend.
-Speaking of sweethearts.
-Yeah, so you're gonna --
This is gonna be a panel?
You're gonna be talking
about comedy to people?
-Yeah. I mean, I guess they're
gonna talk about my life.
You know, "The New Yorker's"
very hoity-toity.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-The Penny Farthing bar?
Is that what that is?
-Yeah, it is the Penny Far--
-That was pretty good, right
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I just researched that
backstage.
[ Laughter ]
Um, but, yeah.
I mean, I'm honored that
they asked me to come out
and, like, talk about myself
I don't know if I was
"New Yorker"-worthy,
but that's nice.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fantastic.
I've long thought
you're "New Yorker"-worthy
-Thank you very much, my friend.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And then, you got David Harbour
hosting the show this week
He was here last night.
What a sweet guy.
-Yeah, well, that's who
I thought you said at first.
That's why I was saying,
"Speaking of sweethearts..."
and then you were like,
"The New Yorker,"
and I was like, "Oh,
that's not the sweetheart.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, wait. Does that mean
you don't think David Remnick'
a sweetheart?
-Well, I haven't met him yet
-Okay, gotcha.
-That was kind of weird,
but I'm sure he is.
[ Laughter ]
But, no.
David Harbour is wonderful
You know, and he's having
a super moment.
He's on, you know,
one of the biggest shows
behind "Game of Thrones,"
I guess.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, I met him over the summer
We were staying
in the same hotel,
and he couldn't have been nicer.
Like, he just,
you know, actor engaged, like,
"Oh, man, break a leg.
I can't wait
to come play with you guys
Blah, blah, blah.
It's gonna be awesome."
I'm like, "Well, look how swee
Sheriff What's-his-face is."
[ Laughter ]
Like, that's amazing.
-Well, I can't wait for that
And it's always such a delight
to see you, buddy.
Everybody, that's
Kenan Thompson. Give it up